I have on air welcome to this Google
hangout for predictions for who will win
the nobel prize in physiology or
medicine for 2014 i'm your moderator
Kate Travis of science news with me
today are several of my colleagues Tina
hesseman is the patina husband say is
the molecular biology reporter at
science news hello next up is Laura
Sanders our neuroscience reporter and
author of the blog growth curve hi and
then there's science news web producer
writer Ashland and writer ashley yeager
who blogs and science ticker off camera
is science news blogger Bethany
brookshire you know her as sigh curious
she is monitoring your tweets for us oh
send your tweets and your questions and
your predictions for the nobel prize in
medicine to the hashtag med Nobel all
right this year's nobel prize in
physiology or medicine will be awarded
on monday october sixth in the wee hours
of us east coast time the prize
typically goes to a maximum of three
people and it's for a major discovery in
physiology or medicine and that's a
pretty broad term interpreted a lot of
different ways over the over the years
depending on what the Nobel Committee
deems worthy of the prize so with that
in mind let's jump right in Tina who is
your pick for this year well I don't
have an exact prediction this year but I
have a hope i really hope that crisper
technology will win i think that prize
would go to Jennifer Doudna and
emmanuelle sharp NT and perhaps George
church can you tell us a little bit for
the for the lay audience what exactly
crispers are crispers are these
molecules that were discovered in
bacteria and make cut up DNA but these
people figured out a way to use them
to edit genes in other species including
humans and so that means that you could
go in and fix a genetic disease
theoretically that's been done in mice
and it's been done in human cells hasn't
been done in people yet of course but I
think that that is coming soon okay I
was going to gonna ask how long has it
been since from discovery till now has
it had enough time to sort of mature
it's very new within the last decade so
it may be too soon for crispers but I
have high hopes that they will be
recognized for their promise ok cool
Laura what about you who wouldn't what's
your critic yeah logo I have to bring an
obvious brain bias into the Horning in
on them the physiology and medicine
prize but i think the deep brain
stimulation for parkinson's disease is
ready for recognition it's a really
promising technique it relies on
sticking electrodes pretty deep into the
brain and stimulating your aunt's in
there and it's it's shown a lot of
promise and might help a lot of people
right now it's in over a hundred
thousand people and I think those
numbers are going to keep growing and I
think the technology itself is going to
be really widely applicable to other
diseases like anxiety and depression um
so I just see a lot of potential for it
okay yeah and Ashley did you have a pic
of yours was kind of techie this year
isn't it yeah I was going to go with
optogenetics as the technique that uses
light to control neurons in 2010 it was
the method of the year for nature
methods and it was highlighted in
science as a breakthrough of the year
and in 20 2013 science used a scientists
use it to make mice that were full keep
eating and make hungry mice not want
food and just recently in August there
was a study where
scientists could reverse good memories
too bad memories and bad memories too
good memories in mice Laura rope I am Oh
a lot about this you can probably chime
in on who the key players are but you're
I was going to say that team from
sloan-kettering and the group from UC
Berkeley would probably be at the top of
the list for creating a technique very
cool I think the Stanford researcher
would be actually the guy who would win
I'm blanking on his name right now our
all nighter off yes I think he's done a
ton of the pioneering work and then add
Boyden it MIT also but it's one of the
pioneers there and I think optogenetics
is a really interesting case because
it's clearly it involves genetically
modifying something so it's really
unlikely that a person would ever have
their genes modified in a way that their
neurons would respond to light but the
technique in mice and other animals um
it tells you these really amazing
intricate things about how the brain
works and that just opens up a ton of
possibilities for other treatments and
you know that it's just a huge untapped
potential when we can understand things
like on that detailed level so yeah I
think it makes a compelling argument for
fourth prize now I will say that I seem
to remember in our in our Nobel Prize
meeting for the staff we were talking
about getting ourselves organized for
the prizes I heard the two of you
talking about how you thought it was too
early for optogenetics it is a little
early for optogenetics and I think it's
more likely to win the chemistry prize
than the medicine prize because the
engineering of these molecules so that
you can turn on and off neurons is
really fascinating and so I think that
has a better shot of winning the
chemistry prize and it might not be too
early to win the chemistry prize but
it's probably too early for the medicine
prize because it it hasn't yet shown its
medical potential Tina do you think it's
too early for Chris
but I do think it's a little early for
crisper but I love Christopher's who you
want to win Tina you also you also had
another one besides who you want to win
you had another one who you wanted to
win who might actually that it's a
little bit more a little bit further
along and that was nuclear receptors
that nuclear hormone receptors so two
years ago I predicted that nuclear
hormone receptors which are things like
estrogen receptor would win I thought it
would win the chemistry prize and I
actually wrote the complete story maybe
the winners and I was like ready to go
when they made the announcement and then
they picked the wrong receptor um but I
really think that nuclear hormone
receptors are incredibly important so
these are things that respond to things
like I said estrogen testosterone all
sorts of things like that they have an
important roles to play in cancer in in
human growth and development in just in
the way the body works and that Pierre
Shambo would be the guy who should
definitely win in Ronald Evans everybody
thought that another guy Elwood Jensen
would have been in on the prize that
he's died and and they don't award the
prize posthumously so it would be
definitely those guys and perhaps one
other person but it's they're sort of
running out of time to award it to
nuclear hormone receptors now i will say
that that was actually i have some some
partners in crime and other magazines
who've been who had other google
hangouts for physics and for chemistry
and here Sean Bowen and Ron Eben's was
carbon drawls pick at chemical and
engineering news
for the chemistry Nobel we see this a
lot we end up we end up banding about
different the same names for different
prizes do you think is that going to be
a trend or something that will see more
of with prizes getting more
interdisciplinary definitely and as I
think that there may be fewer frontiers
in chemistry than there are in molecular
biology and I think something like half
of the last ten chemistry prizes have
actually gone to molecular biologists
and that's something that's a little
irritating for the poor chemist yeah in
the physics hang out just a couple hours
ago they were talking about how physics
some types x takes chemistry to so he
also feels right for chemistry yeah all
right what are some of the prizes that
are kind of like the predictors of the
Nobel like how what how could what can
we look to to know what's the kind of
the top of the top of the line for top
research and where to look to for
possible Nobel contenders so I always
look to the Lasker and the gardener
prizes those two are really a sort of
the prize that you win before you win
the Nobel and there's a number of things
that are on the Lasker and guard girlís
that have not yet won the Nobel Prize
that I I think are really do for
instance molecular motors so these are
tiny little motors that carry around
things inside the cell and are
absolutely necessary for ourselves and
of course open for your body to function
and I think that Michael sheets James
buta JH and Ron Vale would would be the
guys who would take that prize and
that's the that's the prize that cell
biologists have all been waiting for and
again that that could be one that Kidman
the chemist
price as well as the medicine prize what
else I have in mind listen um chaperones
which are proteins that that help other
proteins fold correctly these have
turned out to be really important for
things like Alzheimer's disease and and
all kinds of degenerative nerve diseases
that they help the the proteins fold
correctly and when they don't fold
correctly then you can get these
diseases Arthur horwich and Ulrich
ardell are probably the guys who would
take that and then there's a little bit
of a debate about whether John Ellis or
Susan linked lists might be a third okay
so all sorts of it what about Laura are
there any predictors in neuroscience
that any big prizes in neuroscience that
might predict the Nobel and really no I
mean if it's kind of a dissimilar
sniping like every so often a
neuroscientist will get into the the mix
but there's it's they do seem to be kind
of separate in that regard okay yeah all
right just a reminder to anyone just
joining us that if you want to tweet
your predictions or any questions to the
hashtag med Nobel please do so and we
have Bethany brookshire aside curious
watching behind the scenes and ashley
yeager is on it as well Ashley what are
we hearing from Twitter well we've got
some objections to optogenetics kinetics
any chance I've been an epigenetics
embed on epigenetics yeah and uh Gina
Laura what do you guys think about that
well it would depend on what you're
talking about for epigenetics definitely
I think DNA methylation is right for a
win it's when a gardener prize not yet
when Alaska Pratt's
um Adrian Peter bird Howard cedar and
Erin raisin would probably be the
winners there in showing that DNA
methylation is really important for
determining when and how strongly genes
are turned on and that can affect all
sorts of things in the body and then
there also might fall under the
epigenetic heading is micro RNAs I don't
know that that could win the medicine
prize at this point because they really
haven't been proven in any sort of
medical way but these are very tiny
little snippets of RNA that help control
how much protein gets made in a cell so
that has lots of implications and
especially for cancer and things like
that and people are experimenting with
ways to block these little RNAs in order
to reverse certain cancers or you know
treat other conditions but it's still
pretty early but AB Victor Ambrose and
Gary Rifkin would probably be the
winners if micrornas were selected yeah
i think that the epigenetics idea is
really interesting especially when you
contrast it with just earlier we were
talking about the influence of the human
genome project and and how how
influential and important that project
was and it turns out there's this whole
nother layer of information that we
didn't really know about and just that
discovery is a very powerful reminder of
how far we have to go now complicated
these systems are um for any of these
people if they were to win the Nobel
Prize what does it what does it mean for
a scientist to win the Nobel Prize what
does it mean for their career we joke
about this being the super bowl of
science and you know is it is it that
big of a deal is it life-changing you
know what chloro do you
opinions on that yeah I think in some
ways it's actually kind of funny that it
seems more of a curse to some of the
people I've talked to it it's kind of an
annoyance they get hit up for
conferences they have to weigh in on
panels that's it actually disrupts a lot
of research and in some paradoxical ways
but on the other hand you know they
probably have a little bit better chance
of getting their grant funded so
probably a win I was doing wrong yeah
well often I think it comes really late
in people's careers so it probably
doesn't have much of an impact on their
scientific life and you know that the
money is nice and and I'm sure that they
are very happy that they've been
recognized by their peers as doing such
great caliber work so and on the day
that they win it's like awesome
seriously the happiest day of their life
bar none I think Tina and Ashley you
guys have a story about this right ya
wanna Ashley do you want to take it sure
um so I haven't done much Nobel coverage
and in 2012 i was working at duke
university in their news office and we
we had thought that one of our
engineering researchers would win for
invisibility cloaks so we had prepared
for you know for physics and we didn't
you know we weren't really expecting a
prize winner that year after the physics
prize was announced and then on the
morning of the chemistry prize which i
think was a wednesday that right yeah um
it was you know was about six in the
morning and i had gotten up and was i
was going to go for run and i got a text
message from Tina who I hadn't heard
from since I was an intern in couple
years um and she was asking if she could
get an interview with Robert Lefkowitz
oh I was like oh okay sure I'll see what
I can do about that
in the morning in the morning so that
that day started pretty early for acid
Duke trying to you know figure out where
he was figure out who was in contact
with him how we could set up interviews
and you know also make sure that he
could celebrate the day with his lab and
really appreciate that moment of all the
hard work he's done yeah yeah I'm sure
it's an exciting just an unbelievable
day for for a scientist when they get
that phone call I know from our
perspective we we as journalists we
don't um you know we cover scientific
research usually at science news we
don't cover too many prizes but yet this
whole buzz around the Nobel Prize and
you know we have our planning meetings
and we have you know strategize who's
gonna get up you know we do it in teams
and figure out who's gonna call who at 5
45 in the morning and who's gonna write
the story and who's going to report
who's going to write and all that so
it's certainly exciting from our
perspective Laura you've covered several
Nobel Prizes what what's it like for you
to cover as a journalist it's really fun
it's it is one of those cases of just
you know it's going to be a lot of hard
work and you're going to be very tired
and you're going to probably annoy a lot
of people by calling them over and over
and over until the answer but it's it's
really fun it's a really um it's rare
that in science it's so incremental and
each discovery is you know small and
building on things but this is just a
really clear way to mark a big
achievement you know this is a big deal
let's stop and celebrate it and it's
great it's nice from our perspective too
because we get to we actually get to
because the nobel prize honors this sort
of big achievement we get to tell like a
whole scientific story as yeah just kind
of one little one small one small
component of it so all right well if
it's really fun to when you interview
these people on their big day you know
usually you don't get to actually speak
to the winners because they're so
delicious interview
request and you end up at listening into
some press conference but when Martin
cioffi one for gfp I have been given his
home phone number and so I called his
home phone number and of course I got
voicemail so I left a message but he
called me back because he thought I was
Tina Fey from Saturday Night Live that's
awesome alright well let's get back to
some predictions once again if you're
following along and if you'd like to
send in your predictions or challenge
anybody's predictions here that you can
send those to hashtag med nobel i have a
couple of a couple of predictions that
got emailed in one is from brendan mar
features editor at nature he's pretty
he's putting his money on cancer
genetics or cancer genomics this year
perhaps maryclaire King for the
discovery of the brca1 breast cancer
susceptibility gene or something like
the EP are able the fusion protein
that's responsible for chronic
biological myelogenous leukemia and
discovering the molecule that will
actually attack that and and treat the
cancer any thoughts on either of those
yeah I think those are those are great
possibilities I think genetics has
really revolutionized cancer treatment
and and definitely the the discoverer of
the breast the discovery of the breast
cancer genes was you know one of the
very first and it was really super
important and and dr. King just one
Alaska award this year so you know maybe
she'll double dip and get the the Nobel
as well yeah and i think brian druker
and and two others one Alaska a couple
years ago as well for burdens variable
for CML so so we'll see and then John
Travis the managing news editor at
science has his money on some very
different things one is leptin and
ghrelin I think Tina can you tell us a
little bit about what those are and so
leptin and ghrelin are two hormones that
help control appetite so leptin sort of
suppresses appetite and when it was
discovered it was found in mice that if
mice didn't make leptin then they just
ate and ate and ate and become really
obese and ghrelin does the opposite so
leptin is produced by your fat and so
basically it kind of tells you when
you've had enough and you should stop
ghrelin on the other hand is produced by
your stomach and it stimulates the
appetite so those two molecules are sort
of in opposition to each other and of
course that sounds really great sounds
like the answer to the obesity question
but I think it's become really really
clear that obesity and body weight and
appetite control are just incredibly
complex and there's so many molecules
that are involved in it that i'm not
sure that signally singling out those
two is something that the Nobel
Committee would really do yeah I've
actually written a little bit about the
leptin circuitry to in the brain and it
seems like most people are starting to
say that it's too complicated of a
circuit to really tap into effectively
because if you're producing more left in
your brain cells actually become less
responsive to it so there's no way to
kind of separate those two effects if
you want a cleaner result you can't you
can't tweak it easily
yeah okay all right and one of other I
think we talked about another intriguing
finding or an intriguing idea is the
discovery of artemisinin for malaria and
that that might be a Nobel Nobel Prize
winner any thoughts on that again I
think that's a chemistry prize how about
the synthetic biology angle though
because that's a great example of
tweaking bacteria to produce something
that we really need that otherwise would
be hard to come by oh I can see it I can
see that angle coming into play a little
bit all right well we're coming up on
five minutes left so let's take a quick
look is there anything anything on
Twitter any questions or predictions on
Twitter there was some talk about micro
RNAs being more important than the BRCA
prediction but um the other thing is
what do you think about the chances of
Alfred deaths in for his work and the
tumor suppressor tumor suppressor gene
work so um yeah if if cancer genetics
wins I think he would he would be
included in that so um he's the guy who
came up with this so-called two-hit
hypothesis that you have to have so
certain genes are involved in in keeping
cancer from going forward there those
are called tumor suppressor genes and if
you if one of your copies gets damaged
the other one can still usually
compensate so his idea was that you know
you might have a mutation in one of them
but if the other one was okay you'd be
fine until something happened to you you
know you've got in to radiation or some
chemical exposure or something that
would then damage that second gene and
then you would develop cancer so I think
that was a fundamental
um idea and finding in the cancer
genetics field that would be important
to recognize all right well we're
closing in on the final few minute
Ashley anything else from from Twitter
nope I mean people people are just going
back and forth about you know
optogenetics micrornas they have their
opinions which have you know we can we
can talk about later but uh pretty you
know it's pretty steady no big questions
over here all right what's on your
what's on your watch list you guys
what's the maybe not yet but we'll keep
an eye on it a little win a Nobel Prize
someday well one thing that I'm I'm
really looking forward to as when the
microbiome is going to win there's been
a lot of fascinating work on the
bacteria that live in and on our bodies
and how those influence health in in all
of these very important ways so i think
that's that's coming up it also has that
angle of different a lot of work on
childhood malnutrition in developing
countries and how the microbiome plays
are rolled there and so I could see that
angle coming into the medicine aspect of
the prize yeah I definitely think that
someday that will win but again that's
way too early for for this year's prize
but I definitely think that Jeff Gordon
at Washington University in st. Louis
would be a major contender for that
prize he he kind of really kick-started
that field but there's a lot of people
who who might also share in that prize I
don't know Laura what do you think you
will it be ten years down the line
because right now it's it's pretty
correlative I think another person who
could win in the microbiology prices
stanley hasn't because he has shown that
that gut bacteria when you eat meat they
can convert a chemical in meat into
another chemical that then promotes
hardening of the arteries
and so then you have a very very clear
medical connection between what what
you've got bacteria are doing and your
health yeah yeah and I think I think
what might tip the scales is kind of a
change in public health policy in terms
of antibiotic use I think once once some
of these data become a little clearer to
clinicians they stop prescribing
antibiotics so casually we might see
some real differences in epidemiology
and and maybe that'll be the tipping
point well already we are seeing big
differences there's a stomach bacteria
called helicobacter pylori and it's
known to cause ulcers well in most of
the developing world virtually everybody
has this stuff and so they are more
prone to ulcers and stomach cancer but
in a lot of the Western world people
basically don't have it anymore and so
we're not seeing as many ulcers and
we're not seeing as much stomach cancer
but now we're seeing a rise in
oesophageal cancer because one of the
things that you look go back to pylori
does is help to suppress the acid in the
stomach and so you don't get that the
acid reflux damaging your esophagus and
then possibly leading to to cancer all
right final question we're in our last
minute who's been waiting for to get
their Nobel Prize for forever and will
this be their year ah Bruce Hanes who
invented the so-called aims test which
is to test how muta genetic how
mutagenic chemicals are so you use
bacteria to see if a chemical is harmful
to your DNA and also Carl geraci who
invented that the chemistry that made
the birth control pill possible you know
they really been on the list
forever and ever they are the perennial
bridesmaids but the fact that they
haven't won kind of makes me feel like
they want when they won't win yeah Laura
any Laura Ashley any any of the video
bridesmaids so to speak when ya when it
occurred to me was a Norman pace at the
University of Colorado getting back to
the microbiome he figured out ways to
actually measure bacteria that aren't
growing on dishes and labs and that was
a pretty fundamental I'll break through
and allowed us to look at things that we
would otherwise be completely blind to
so yeah good anybody else anything all
right I think we will go ahead and wrap
it up them I think that's the end of our
hangout but that is not the end of the
discussion keeping discussion oh my god
Twitter for all of the prizes at med
note hashtag med Nobel hashtag fizz
Nobel hashtag chem Nobel and on this
google hangout page are the links to all
of the youtube videos for the hangouts
if you'd like to go back and watch and
see what everyone who everyone else
picked and then stay tuned on Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday for the actual
announcements of the actual Nobel prizes
monday is medicine and then and tuesday
is physics and wednesday is chemistry
i'd like to give a special shout out to
my partners in crime in this series of
of hangouts victoria Jaggard at
Smithsonian and Carmen draw at chemical
and engineering news Carmen did this
last year and she led us a jump on the
bandwagon too and so who said nothing
good ever happened at happy hour on
behalf of our esteemed panel tina has
been say Laura Sanders ashley yeager and
Bethany brookshire thank you for
watching goodbye goodbye